this
is a special father's day episode of
sadler's stories and i'm going to tell
you something about
my dad my adoptive father anton sadler
a memory that i had having to do with a
horror story
and something very nice that he did for
me
as a kid and this would have been
towards the end
of his life when i was either 10 or 11
we didn't know of course that that his
death was going to be happening
not that long after that and it had to
do
with him doing a task for me something
that i asked him to do and which was
you know not the most onerous thing to
do in the world but involved some
difficulty and some some work on on his
part which he was
quite willing to do and so i'll tell you
the story and it has to do with
another story as well because that's
part of
what he what he did for me so
again i don't remember whether i was 10
or 11
but i do remember it must have been
11 because i was at university lake
school and i remember that it was in the
spring
and i got my hands on a book of horror
stories
i had been reading horror stories since
i was a kid my great-uncle hubert who
i've talked about in another
video he was very big on us
reading and he would get me these alfred
hitchcock
anthologies every year which were kind
of for kids but also
really kind of not for kids but they
were for the kind of kid that i was
so you know monster museum and uh
haunted household and all those sorts of
things they had classic
horror stories in them and i got my
hands on this this other one
and it had a story in it um
called kalamander chest by joseph payne
brennan and i think that it was actually
his anthology called nine horrors
and a dream that was published in 1958
with
arkham house which is based here in
wisconsin
founded by august durleth you know
big big horror and sci-fi person
associated with hp lovecraft but also
with many other
writers we'll talk about that in just a
moment so i got
my hands on this book and it had a bunch
of
stories in it i remember that and
i asked my dad because i knew that he
had
access to a photocopy machine and
remember we're talking at this point
probably
you know it must have been yeah um
1981 i'm guessing um
and so we we we had photocopiers at that
time but it was kind of a rare
thing and photocopies were expensive you
paid a good bit good bit for them so he
had a photocopier
at work he was working for tuschross
here in milwaukee and um
he was a tax attorney uh and
so you know he was kind of you know well
placed in the office but he wasn't one
of the partners
so you know he would have been kind of
in the pecking order
and it would have been kind of weird for
him to be doing
photocopies and he told me i'm gonna
have to photocopy these after work so
people don't see me
doing them um i'm not sure exactly what
the story was but
i gathered that it was a task but he was
willing to do it and
and i i asked him believe it or not i
asked him if he'd photocopy the whole
book for me
and he said i can almost only photocopy
4 stories i don't know why it was
four but there were four and so i kind
of just picked them
out uh here and there and i don't
remember what the other stories were i
only remember
this one particular story the
kalamander chest so
one night he he came back from from work
and
he handed these photocopies to me
and he said here you go here's your four
stories
and i remember i would read at night
past lights out and the way that i would
do it
was not the way a lot of other kids
would like a flashlight or something so
i had a nightlight
and i don't know if my parents actually
knew this or not
i didn't really need the night light
a night light if you don't know what it
is it's a little tiny bulb
and you plug it into an outlet and it's
got like usually like a little thing
around it so it's not
casting direct light on you and it's for
kids who are
scared of the dark i actually wasn't
scared of the dark
although after reading one of these
stories that was a little bit different
[Music]
and what i would do is they they knew
that i loved to read
you know i i first learned how to read
when i was about three
and i just you know read voraciously and
it was
one of the things that i i really took a
lot of enjoyment in
so my parents you know my bedtime was
nine o'clock on school nights
and i was supposed to have the lights
out by that time
so what i what i would do is i'd leave
the nightlight on and then i would
listen for them to go downstairs and i
would go over by the night light
and if it was cold you know i'd have my
like my blanket on me and i'd read by
the nightlight
i i think i probably you know didn't do
my eyes any favor
by by engaging in that behavior that
might be why i have to wear
glasses although maybe some of it's just
a bad luck with my eyes
and so sometimes i would read for an
hour or two
you know if i knew that if i had my
actual light on they would see that
but the nightlight i was good and if i
heard them coming up the stairs i would
get under my covers and pretend to be
asleep and
you know hide whatever i was reading
somewhere so i read that story by the
nightlight
and that was quite a scary night because
the the story the
callow uh kalamander chesk so kalamander
i guess is a kind of wood
um it's a short story
and it's pretty well constructed there's
a guy
and he buys a calamander chest the
previous owner
you know nobody knows what uh became of
them until later on in the story
uh the chest is being sold really cheap
and i guess you know it's kind of a nice
piece of furniture so he buys it and he
polishes it up and he's got it in his in
his bedroom
and then the first night that he's awake
the
chest opens up already we're getting
kind of horror stuff right oh what's
happening here
and it gets worse a single finger comes
out
and the fingers out of a corpse a dead
person
and it beckons to the guy
and he finds himself sort of
hypnotically
drawn by this and he gets up out of bed
and starts walking over to the chest and
the way that the
author described it there's a sense that
things are really wrong that if he
reaches this chest
it something bad is going to happen to
him but he can't
he can't stop himself from walking to it
and then he wakes up and it's the
morning and
he thinks oh there must have been a bad
dream you know things don't
happen like that in real life and of
course
he doesn't do anything and then the next
night you know the finger comes out
and beckons him again and he's closer to
it when he gets away if i'm remembering
the story right
then he's i gotta lock this chest up now
he's actually
feeling like something is is wrong and
he
he um arranges for it to be taken away
by workmen
but they say oh we can't do it today
we'll come by tomorrow and get the chest
for you
um you know landlord will let us in and
we'll we'll take care of it
so he goes to bed and now he's got the
chest locked
so and there's a key in the lock so it's
not going to be a big deal right
and then he hears this sound of the key
sliding
and it falls on the floor and
now coming out of the keyhole is the
finger
and it's gesturing to him come here
and he gets up and he goes over to the
chest
and either the chest is unlocked or he
unlocks it himself
and he gets into the chest
and that's that's the last that we hear
of him then there's sort of like a flash
forward
with the workmen complaining about how
heavy the chest is as they're taking it
out
and uh he's you know he's that didn't go
on and that's what happened apparently
to the previous owner
who was found dead in the chest so a
really good horror story
uh by this uh joseph payne brennan um
i found it great literature
and also terrifying at the same time
that you know the way he described the
the finger
so flash forward i've read the story
now i'm going to bed and of course i'm
now kind of scared
and my imagination is going wild i get
through the night i don't have any bad
dreams about
the finger but it's still kind of
lingering with me and my dad
you know understandably enough asks me
so how did you how did you like the
stories you know are they any good
and i didn't want to tell him that i
had scared myself you know
with reading this story and my own
imagination
coming from it so i don't remember
exactly what i told them but it was
some sort of cover story like oh they
were good but you know not that scary
and the irony is so a little bit of
digression here
my dad also had a knack for horror
when when i was much younger like
elementary school age
probably you know first or second grade
as our neighborhood was
beginning to fill up with other families
and kids um so it must actually been
like third or fourth grade
uh we we had this this wonderful
fieldstone
fireplace in our house in in the living
room in the house was one
that my dad had you know bought the land
for
and worked with an architect he and my
mom to design the house the way that
they wanted it was a two-story
that had like a a living room which was
kind of
fancy you know with the books and the
nice furniture and then a
family room as you call it where it was
much more rough and tumble
and there was this you know like i said
great fieldstone
fireplace that had a big wide mouth and
we used to
not just you know have fires in there
but like roast marshmallows
and sometimes you know cook things on
the fire
and it was it was really nice to do and
we'd have like you know
wood piled up alongside the garage
that i i you know he taught me how to
split it and i would do that
anyway um we'd have fires quite often
and you know have hot chocolate and
snacks and things like that
so during the fires he would tell
stories
and the stories that he would tell were
pretty scary stories
they weren't that scary for me although
i think my sister got a bit scared
but they terrified the neighborhood kids
so much on the few occasions that they
came over to like you know for story
time and a fire
that they went home and had bad dreams
and nightmares and
didn't you know want to go to sleep and
their parents actually called my dad
and complained that he needed to tone
the stories down i remember him telling
stories about werewolves and
all sorts of things like that and and he
you know he would tell the stories they
weren't just
short campfire yarn they would go on and
on and on there were there were quite a
lot of
elements to them so to speak and maybe
that's what made them so
vivid for these poor kids and these were
kids that i thought were you know
sometimes tougher than me
but when it came to my dad's stories
they um
they were all wimps and so anyway long
story short
um i didn't for some reason i didn't
want to tell my dad
about the scary finger and how how much
it had gotten
to me and i never did tell him
i i don't think i ever brought that up
and
i remember later on so this is shifting
topic a little bit
you know this is after he died i still
had those four
photocopied stories around and
i remember thinking to myself what an
effort he had gone to
to do this thing for me that i was
asking him to do
that he wasn't supposed to be doing but
he was willing to do
anyway for me because i was
his kid and it was you know something he
he wanted to do
you could say well you know is it a good
father who's breaking the rules for
their kid
and i would say well in the case of my
dad yeah um i mean he was also somebody
who was an incredibly hard worker
i'm sure that he was a major asset to
his firm because you know
not too long after that they sent him
down to houston
to open up the new office for touch ross
which was expanding
all over the the place at that time
so they clearly had some some confidence
in his abilities and he was a very smart
guy and a very
uh very astute person the way he engaged
with other people
so that was something that we uh shared
in common was this
interest in horror actually i'll tell
you one other thing about
horror and sci-fi that has to do with
him that kind of
consolidates this so as i mentioned my
bedtime was
nine o'clock when i was that age
but there was one exception on saturday
nights
we could watch he and i shock theater
and shock theater was this
um this show it's sort of like what they
had in chicago
with son of fenguli which was based
there in chicago
we had something like that up here in
milwaukee on the independent
channel channel 18 and what what it was
is a guy who would like you know wear
like um
you know corpse makeup essentially with
what they nowadays associate with like
death metal and stuff like that but
at this time it was more like a
halloween sort of thing
and uh he would um he would
talk he would introduce a movie either a
horror movie or a fantasy movie or a
sci-fi movie and they were usually
pretty schlocky
you know like we saw soylent green and
we saw um
a bunch of of like sci-fi things with
you know
people zapping each other we saw some
older movies that had like the
you know anime not animatronic but you
know whatever it was
that they were doing with a stop-motion
photography with the
uh monsters and and uh
animals and things you know dinosaurs
and things like that
so we would watch these movies and that
meant i got to stay up with him until
about midnight or sometimes
even after that he we'd make some
popcorn and we'd hang out and watch this
movie i remember one was called green
slime
and it was it was on like a space
station
or something and green slime it had this
terrible song that went with it you know
green slime
uh did you hear what the captain said
green slime you'll believe it when
you're dead
and it was that sort of thing and then
not svengoolie but
the shock theater guy forget his name he
would burst in and say some crazy stuff
uh before it would go to commercial
right and then it would go to commercial
and
the movie would come back and he'd he'd
make fun of the movie it was sort of
like in a way
mystery science uh what is it 3000 or
whatever it is
long before that existed um and so there
were
there were different shows like that and
we would watch those and uh
you know we we'd talk about that when we
go fishing and
um so he was a cool dad when it came to
horror and science fiction
and that story um was was really
something you know thinking back to it
again
um this guy who you know
if if he were brought back to life today
he would be much younger than i am
now i'm just thinking about him this guy
who was such a hard worker and had so
many responsibilities
and yet he found the time to make
photocopies
for his you know crazy request
from his kid who is interested in this
joseph payne brennan
story and um yeah he was a cool guy so
i'll just
end it there i think that's probably
enough said about this
um maybe some of you have similar
stories or
you know tangents that that are
connected to this in some way i will
point out too that
i do think it was nine horrors in a
dream
from arkham house and that would be kind
of a cool thing
if it is true because arkham house
august durlith based it here in
wisconsin in sauk city
that was a major press
for fantasy horror science fiction
um he's the one who you know put h.p
lovecraft stuff
back on the map and so apparently
um brendan worked with derlith and
became friends with him
uh and so that's why it was at arkham
house it would make sense that
the copies of it would be in
libraries around here because you know
distribution in the wisconsin
area so yeah that that's a good place to
leave off
with that little footnote and i hope you
enjoyed the story
you